hello everyone and welcome back to the
chess 24 legends of chess tournament
with a truly spectacular game uh from
round three
uh it's game four of the match uh
vaseline vancouver versus dingleran
and this has been brought to my
attention only recently uh it seems that
uh i've uh constantly been spelling uh
uh vasily evan chuck uh when
it's actually vassal it's the ukrainian
version of the name and it's the one of
course
he himself prefers so i feel kind of
silly that i've been uh
you know writing it differently and
pronouncing it differently all this time
but i
i never knew this uh so sorry about that
and that we are going to do it like this
uh from from this point
onwards and this is uh it was truly a
great match i mean i can't show all the
games since there are four games at
least being played every day
uh between two players and even more if
they go into armageddon so
i can't show all of them but i will try
to show the the nicest ones
and this one is really incredible in
game one uh dink had a
brilliant winning tactic he missed it
and the game ended in a draw
then uh vassell took the win in the
second game being retaliated in the
third game and this is now game four
whoever wins it wins the match or if
it's a draw we go into armageddon
so uh let's check it out uh vessel with
the white pieces opens with
d4 we have knight to f6 biting the c for
e6 and
now knight to c3 uh inviting ding to a
nice nimso indian which he does go for
so bishop to b4
uh the names of indian defenses on the
board and we have knight to f3
uh the three knights variation of the
nimzo we have castles biting uh
and now e3 uh sorry e3
uh and here uh the most common uh move
here
as it is in most lines of the nimzo is
d5 however ding goes for the very old
line bishop captures on c3
it's been tried it not it's not really
an old line it's sort of a
line that was played very very few times
and attempted
a couple of times in in modern chess
bishop captures on c3 so he tries to
catch a
vassal off of guard a b captures on c3
and
now d6 but not just bishop to d3
continuing development and now e5
already threatening e4 to win some
material here
so uh there is one game in the database
where knights the d2 was played but here
vassal goes for e4 and it is already as
of move 80 that we have a completely new
game
so what did ding have in mind here we
have e capture sunday for c capture
sunday for in the rook the e8
uh our vassal's king is still in the
center of the board so it does make
sense to try and keep him there for as
long as possible puts pressure on the e4
pawn
however we have a kingside castle
sacrificing this pawn
and what's the what's the compensation
here for the sacrifice pawn
well black still has to develop a lot of
his pieces so
it will take time to grab that pawn uh
but dean goes for it we have knight
captures on e4 and
there is nothing wrong with capturing
the four it is in fact the strongest
move recommended by the engine
uh with rook to e1 now with a double
attack here and the knight just
goes back to f6 with rook character 78
knight capture 78 and now bishop to g5
asking ding do you want to go back do
you want to play something like f6 do
you want to move the queen
so a lot of things are possible here for
example if knight f6 you
maybe run into into this pin but it's
not really
the pin that's important because you can
just trade here and threaten checkmate
with queen e2 and once this is prevented
rook e1 again every move you develop you
threaten checkmate so bishop b7
and now you could play this but it's um
looks very very ugly for black you have
some very very uh clean moves here for
white you're gonna play d5 at some point
grab more space in the center and
it it should be playable however for a
rapid game it's hard to say
black will feel very comfortable here so
instead after this bishop g5 move we
have f6 biting
uh pushing the bishop back with bishop
back to d2
and now knight to d7 this knight is now
coming to f8
uh to add more support to the h7 pawn as
you know that
uh vasso is coming after you so
queen c2 putting pressure on h7 and
knight f8 defending the h7 pawn
and now rook to e1 so just uh
completing development and black still
has to figure out how to develop his
pieces
so c6 preparing to strike in the center
with d5 and now even
a4 and here uh
here vassal shows that it's not all that
easy to develop with black
you still need a way of just completing
development for example if you bishop to
g4
uh you just run into knights to h4 and
it's just again
what what are you gonna do here for
example if rook b8 you you maybe start
pushing some pawns or something h3
you push the bishop back and knight f5
and now with this knight on f5 it's just
a very
very deadly square rook is coming to e7
after that you will have a lot of
pressure here
so it's a a very difficult position to
play for black so after this
a4 move with knight to c7 by ding
now grabbing hold of the e6 square but
now d5
not allowing any piece to land on e6
with c5 biting
and now knight to h4s plan going after
this
f5 square so here we have knight to a6
uh ding wants to bring his uh knight
over to b4 to put pressure on the queen
and the bishop to win
at least one of the bishops as you
either will lose the light square bishop
or you will have to give up the dark
square bishop
so here we have bishop to f5
playing knight to f5 right away also
looks very appealing however this runs
into knights to b4 and now you either
lose the
uh the bishop pair or you go for 97
check but
then black can just capture it and after
rook captures you can capture the queen
captures and now let's say b6 you're
gonna develop your bishop bring the rook
into the game and it's uh
it's a it's a pretty good position for
black uh he he will not be worried so
here instead after knight to a6 with
bishop to f5
he wants to win the f5 outpost for the
knight he doesn't want uh this bishop to
be traded for night
uh still knights to b4 by ding and queen
to e
for now and here just bishop to d7
asking uh white what do you want to do
if you capture here i will nicely
recapture and then bring my rook into
the game but other than that i'm also
just
threatening to pick up the a4 pawn and
then create a nice past a pawn for
myself
so here uh vassal goes for rook to e3 he
says
i'm not interested in the pawn i'm just
going to do a nice rook lift maybe rook
g3 rook h3
depending on what black plays uh and
here uh again it's very hard
to to decide what to do if you capture
something like bishop captures an f5
after knight captures its game over for
black
there's no no no playing this for black
whatever you play
uh let's say queen d7 queen g4 and
there is too much pressure here you are
threatening this well okay first you're
threatening this the
get the queen away from the defense of
this spawn and then it's adjust the game
over
uh but also if you try and stop this
just knight h6 check and you pick up the
queen so
very very difficult position to play for
black so instead uh ding just went for
bishop captures on a4 and this is the
most uh
of all the poison pawns this guy is the
most poisoned
as uh now the game is completely lost
for ding uh and it's actually a forced
checkmate in seven moves so uh feel free
to pause the video here
while i give you a couple of seconds
find the winning idea for white
as it's just spectacular
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting the
mating pattern as this is not an easy
one to find and for those who
just want to enjoy the show it's bishop
captures an h7 and now
the reason why it's so beautiful is that
after knight captures on h7
you get queen e6 check and now wherever
the king goes
knight g6 is checkmate so this is
checkmate as the
queen now covers this nice uh check made
by the knight
and also if the king goes to h8 still
the same thing just
check uh it's made queen covers this the
knight blocks the king
so ding of course cannot capture the
bishop he has to move it uh and
where are you going to move it uh so
king the f7 h8
is also not very pleasant because if you
go to h8
then it's the very unpleasant knight the
g6 check
and now after knight captures and g6
bishop captures
now queen is coming to to finish the job
whatever you play doesn't really matter
you can try something like f5
now even rook to h3 is sufficient king
the g8 queen e6 check king of f8 and now
this will be checkmate
so really really incredible stuff so uh
point being after bishop captures here
king to f7 by ding but now comes uh
knight to f5 and this is the move that
was not easy to find
uh because the bishop now covers these
two squares these two escape squares for
the king and that there isn't much you
can do to prevent
checkmate so if you try something like
queen
let's say i don't know queen to e8
knights the d6 is made because again the
bishop covers this
the knight checks and the queen prevents
the king from reaching the e file
if you play something like queen to d7
let's say you try and keep an eye on
this
pawn maybe try and bring the rook into
the game with something like this as the
bishop and queen still cover that
doesn't really matter queen e6 check
captures and this is now mate
the knight nicely covers the rook and
the bishop still covers this
so after this knight to f5 move ding
tried the only thing that's left
just eliminate this guy that's
preventing us from escaping
but now comes the the third brilliancy
another bolt from the blue
uh knight to h6 check and it was in this
position that the iglorian resigned the
game as now there's nothing more to be
done here
uh if the knight is captured with g
captures uh well then it's just queen
captures the rook prevents the king from
reaching the e file
king f8 and now the the uh uh
crushing idea rook to g3 rook g3 now
there is no defense rook to g8 will be
made in one whatever
black plays so we can just make a silly
move uh just to deliver mate rook to g8
and that's just it
and the other thing after knight to h6
check if you don't capture the knight
if you just move the king let's say king
of fate it's the same idea just queen
captures here with the threat of queen
g8 to checkmate and
there's nothing you can do if you
capture the knight we get the exact same
position where the rook the g3 just
finishes the game so whatever you play
let's now play another silly move just
rook to g8 and this is checkmate
and so i don't forget uh i would like to
take this opportunity to award
uh a vassal evan chook once again in
this tournament
a nice morphe head oops uh there we go
so nice morphe head for
uh for good ol chucky uh brilliant
brilliant attacking game and
once didn't grab that a41 it was just
all over uh and it's not
not easy to find all these patterns i
mean this is something
of of course uh for for uh for vassal
this is
something he knows that because he he
saw this made probably a million times
and he recognizes the patterns but you
know just to spot it
right you know just like that it's a
pretty crazy stuff
uh but yeah a wonderful game so i really
do hope you enjoyed it and these are the
standings after round three
so let's just check that out before we
head into uh round four so here they are
whoops layers uh magnus carlsen and
peter svidler leading the tournament
with
nine full points each uh then we have
uh yanni pomnishi with eight points what
is girlfriend with six with four points
we have vaseline vancouver and vladimir
kramnik
with three anishigiri peter leko with
two and still with zero points
vishwanathan anand and the ding
lyrin so crazy tournament uh
younger players versus the the chess
legends uh
really really enjoying this one hope you
guys are as well and we are going to
continue in this fashion
so once again i do hope you enjoyed it i
would like to thank ross martin will
rubenstein
even lover of isaac drum and uh jaco
hans for your contribution to my channel
thank you a lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the chess 24
legends of chess checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the chess world
so thank y'all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your friday